there was the attack in Brussels last
week just a few days ago there was the
attack in Pakistan it seems to me that
these things are starting to become more
frequent and there's just a feeling that
now you know I saw something this week
that they're saying that there's
probably 400 Isis operatives in Europe
ready to partake in whatever the next
event is gonna be so can you just break
down Brussels a little bit because I
know for weeks before people were saying
this was about to happen so they
obviously had good intelligence and it
still happened and I think that's what
the really scary part is yes I mean
obviously what happened in Brussels is
absolutely horrific but it was not to me
at least it was not a surprise you know
it was coming we knew that and you were
just saying that obviously we had good
intelligence well you have to
distinguish there a bit but because
obviously that the Belgian authorities
didn't have the intelligence that they
were supposed to be having and that is a
problem that people like myself have
raised for quite a long time now that
the very weak nature of the Belgian
State I mean it's sometimes even
problematic to speak of Belgium as a
state because it's so torn apart
internally and the the state of the
Belgium secret services and intelligence
services they are ill-equipped they are
massively undersized and they simply
don't have the resources to monitor all
the people that they are actually
supposed to be monitoring because let's
not forget that Belgium has the highest
percentage per capita or foreign
fighters with the Islamic state in the
entire European Union and it's no it's
no coincidence that these people have
chosen Belgium as a place where they can
gather and plan and carry out attacks
because of course they are well aware of
all these weaknesses that I've just
listed and you know by failing their own
people Belgium is putting everyone else
at risk because obviously these people
do not appreciate
you know someone in France or someone in
Germany or the UK it's just as much an
enemy to these people as the people of
Belgium and it can openly cross borders
I mean we have we still have to share an
area in in Europe where people can cross
borders without showing their passports
or any form of identification and that's
why we are seeing the Terrorism that we
see and that's also why we see a network
really spamming from from Paris to
Belgium and this was the first time ever
that one terrorist cell managed to
attack two European capitals yeah did
you hear any I saw a story that I saw in
one place
and then I didn't see it picked up
anywhere else so if this is not true
please stop me but I stirred that when
they were going to arrest the guy in
Belgium just a week ago that apparently
that in his community that about 200
people were trying to stop the police
and the anti-terror people from
arresting and they were throwing bottles
at the police and all kinds of stuff did
you hear about that and is it being
reported in Europe at all I heard about
that as well I think some media outlets
reported that there were riots taking
place when they arrested him and to be
honest it's not surprising to me at all
because you have to understand these
people don't work in isolation they are
embedded in communities and if you look
at these notorious neighborhoods like
molenbeek in Belgium it's not just the
terrorists that are the problem
it's the wireless society in which they
live who maybe are not jihadist
themselves and who not engaged in
violence themselves but who are at least
to a certain degree described to the
Islamist ideology which brings me to the
overall problem really that it's not
good enough to say this is just a
problem with a fringe because yes there
is only a tiny minority that carries out
violent attacks but there is a larger
minority that subscribe to the Islamist
worldview and an even larger minority a
significant minority that practices
conservative Islam that is not
compatible with the modern world and we
are not talking
a few hundred or a few thousand people
here we are talking millions and even if
you say they're just 1% of all Muslims
in the world are jihadists we are
talking about 15 or 16 million people
yeah I mean wrap your head around this
for a moment ya know it's incredible and
I know that many people like sam harris
who i've had on this show have gone out
of their way to talk about these
concentric circles and you have the
nominal people who don't necessarily
care about religion or following
doctrine and then it sort of extends
outward from that so what do we do with
that because this is where the
conversation gets difficult so you've
obviously just laid out there that you
don't think all Muslims are doing this
but you do see you know certain amount
of problems a certain amount of people
are going to use violence a certain
amount of people are gonna condone that
violence a certain amount of people are
gonna see it brewing in their
communities and not do anything and then
it just keeps it's like an onion there's
just more and more layers so how do we
in the West combat that because we're
fighting we're fighting the people we're
fighting them and then we're fighting
the people on our left who are trying to
silence us from talking about it well I
think one one good example it's your
show really because you equip people
with the rhetoric to to engage in just
daily live in these debates as well and
to make the distinction between the
religion of Islam which is a set of
believes and Islamism
which is an ideology which partly
derives from a particular interpretation
of the religion and jihadism which then
is sort of the violent extension of
Islamism so I think that's first of all
a distinction that's very important to
make because it also makes it easier for
people like ourselves to reject you know
charges of racism and bigotry and
Islamophobia yeah don't you get
exhausted by making the distinction
though because it almost doesn't win you
any friends on the left because that's
how I feel but I'll continue to do it
exactly I mean I don't really have
another choice right I mean the other
option would be to to join doughnut
Donald Trump camp I just
and stigmatized or Muslims and that's
really not what I want to see I mean
that it's Dennis precisely why I'm not a
bigger that's not a race I don't want to
engage in these generalizations and
sweeping statements and brushing every
everyone over the same ha I don't want
to do that and that is why I keep
explaining to people there is a
difference between a religion and Islam
is a religion like any other religion it
is a set of beliefs and we should have
the right to criticize particular
beliefs within the faith if they are
harmful and incompatible with a modern
way of life and you know I sometimes
call I sometimes call Islam the Virgen
amongst faith because you are not
allowed to touch it you are not allowed
to touch virgin they are happy to
discuss with you
gender inequality when it comes to
Orthodox Judaism right and they are
quite happy to discuss with you bigoted
views on the fundamentalist Christian
right about abortion and women and about
the Crusades don't forget about the
Crusades they love the Crusades don't
forget what we did there you know they
talk about the persecution of Muslims in
Burma by five Buddhist extremists and
they are not they don't hesitate to call
them Buddhist extremist and make the
religion into the religion of Buddhism
but when it comes to Islam it's off
topic you are not allowed to touch Islam
the moment you touch Islam you are a
bigger you're a racist no matter what
distinction you're making between the
religion and the ideology and and
jihadism you're a racist that very
moment you you you want to talk about
Islam yeah so basically you'll continue
to make this distinction because we sort
of have no choice I mean that's how
that's how I feel too because I don't
want to hand it to to the far right but
that's a good segue to a lot of what's
happening in Europe right now so you
mentioned earlier that because of the
European Union you know that there that
people don't have to use passports to go
all over the place so this is why the
ideology can spread and it's why people
can can go from Paris to to Brussels so
two questions here one is people seem to
want
there's a certain amount of people that
want to break up the EU altogether and
secondly I want to talk about
immigration as a whole so I why don't we
start with the first one well yeah
obviously there is a debate going on
everywhere in Europe about open borders
because many people feel like it's no
longer in essence and rather aiding
those people that we are trying to
contain I mean I I always as a European
myself I always felt it was great that I
could just cross the border when I lived
to Germany I thought it was great to
just cross the border into the
Netherlands or Belgium or France without
having to show my passport it's great
but the problem is if you have a system
like open borders you also need adequate
security to back this are and what the
Belgium example shows you is that right
now we are not having the security
apparatus that can safeguard our tasks
whilst having open borders because if
Belgium is failing to contain the threat
and that's what they are doing and have
been doing for a long time and these
people can travel freely across the
entire European Union it's a little
different with the UK because you have
to cross some water and it's more
complex right but into France or Germany
or the Netherlands then we all have
we're having a problem and we have to
talk about it and I'm not even I'm not
very partisan when it comes to this
entire yes you unti EU debate but I do
think that we have to honestly talk
about the liabilities of open borders at
the moment and that is true for
terrorists as much as it is for refugees
do you know is the vetting process for
the migrants and the immigrants is it
the same in each country because if
they're all let's say they're coming
through Greece if Greece has more lacks
processes by which they can get in well
then if you once you're in Greece if you
can then get anywhere in Europe I could
see why you would be pretty pissed if
you were in France and Greece had leat
lacks you know ways to get people in
well the truth is that all of these
countries are actually overwhelmed they
cannot process all these people in time
that that they are arriving and the
truth is also that many
them are just throwing away their papers
so you have no way to even you know
check who they are where they coming
from and the truth is also that many of
them actually not coming from Syria they
also coming from countries like
Afghanistan and Eritrea and I feel like
the biggest problem at the moment is
that we are only treating the symptoms
we are not treating the root cause
because what is the plan for Irit Riya
mm-hmm nobody is talking about Eritrea
what are we going to do about the
citroen in Eritrea to make sure that not
more people that coming I mean we have
to look at these countries and the
situation in these countries and we have
to ask ourselves what can we do to
change the situation on the ground and
to help people within their own region
because the truth is that even a large
country like Germany a welcoming country
like Germany cannot take in all the
people that need help and how do you
explain to someone from Libya that yes
we are taking in people from Syria and
Eritrea and Afghanistan but no you
Olivia please stay away
we can't discriminate there and the
truth is that we cannot take in all
these people and my fear is that Angela
Merkel has sent a very dangerous message
in the sense that people now believe
everybody can come and we are if you
look at the situation in Germany at the
moment you see they are already
struggling I know that the government is
not willing to admit that but if you
look at the situation on the ground they
are really really struggling and the
opposition within even her own party is
growing by the day yeah so this is an
example where when I hear this I always
say well the road to hell is paved with
good intentions so angle the Merkel her
intentions by bringing these people in
were to help immigrants right help
migrants help people that needed help
integrate them into society obviously
Germany has a long history of xenophobia
and and the Holocaust so they were
trying to do the right thing I don't
think you know I talked to people who
think that she maliciously is trying to
destroy the country I don't quite think
it's that I think she was trying to do
something good here but then
because of I guess the questionable
vetting process or just allowing too
many people and these people come in and
then the system just can't take it and
then when people in other countries see
what's happening in a Germany they don't
want it happening there so this whole
thing is just has just snow balled and
is it too late
have we already left this that the only
resolution will be that far-right
parties are gonna win throughout Europe
what first of all I agree with you that
I don't think this is an evil master
plan of Angela Merkel to destroy Germany
or do union I don't believe that I I
believe for whatever reasons she
believes this is the right thing to do
the problem is I recently spoke to
friends of mine who sits in the German
parliament for her party for the CDU and
he said even now we are still not having
a discussion about quota you know that
there is no end to this that they used
even the people within her own party
don't know where it stops and that of
course gives people like the far-right
in Germany and we see you know the
pegida movement and we see the what is
called alternative for Germany these
people are really gaining support a
really gaining ground and these are of
course not the people that we want to
hand the debate over to and I know that
there are people who try to remember sky
as movements like piggy dye and say oh
you know they are just concerned
citizens who take to the streets and
exercise their right of free speech but
you know I I'm quite familiar with a
neo-nazi scene in Germany and I look at
footage from pegida demonstrations and
you see very well-known people from the
neo-nazi scene taking part in these
demonstrations and I'm not a fan of
guilty by association I mean you cannot
always control who comes to your
demonstrations but it's I mean this guy
gave an interview to one of Germany's
well-known political magazines and very
openly admitted that the NPD which is
the neo-nazi party in the country helped
bagheera
to organize this particular
demonstration in the east of Germany so
you see already you know the lines
blurring between the populist right and
really the
extreme extreme rides yeah I'm curious
let's dig into Paquita a little bit more
because I had Tommy Robinson on the show
and you know a lot of people were very
angry at me I got a lot of hate mail for
even just talking to the guy now I think
in the context of the hour of our
conversation he did basically make the
distinction between ideas and people and
all of those things and after the
interview which I thought was pretty
fruitful people did send me tweets that
he sent out years before where he was
talking about all Muslims and there
clearly was an element of bigotry to it
I can't vet my guests tweets from from
five years ago unfortunately but what do
you make of someone like him that I
think from what I can tell he's trying
to make the distinction he and I know
he's left organizations when it's gone
too far right or when they were bigoted
against black people I guess that just
shows the complexity of this that these
organizations they have all kinds of
people in them yeah I mean Tommy
Robertson is a is a very tricky example
and I don't want to dive too much into
this because to be fair I'm not familiar
with everything that he's doing at the
moment I mean I what I know is because I
we work with Quilliam as well and I know
Maajid Nawaz that he was really trying
to get him away from the idea and I was
making an attempt to engage with him and
and explain to him the difference
between you know the religion of Islam
which is a set of leaves and Islam is
now ideology and Muslims as people and
alarm as as a system of believes and I
think to some extent if you listening to
what he's saying now he has definitely
made some progress but I don't want to I
don't want to sort of approve of
everything that he says because I still
believe that some of the views that he
holds problematic to say the least and
for instances involvement in the pegida
movement that is something that I do not
approve of and I do not believe that
pegida is a legitimate political well
it's legitimate in a sense that these
people have the right to speak their
minds but not legitimate in the sense
that I would ever support their views